persévérant
ont passionné
la juge joël dont vous aviez 52 ans un
petit tilloy donc investi j'ai commencé
en tant que vas tu dans une association
et rencontrant les difficultés des
personnes à saint céré je me suis
investi en tant que professionnel
militants et en même temps avec une
volonté de trouver des solutions
je suis chez des gens qui me connaissent
donc je peux rentrer comme ça
centraide gagner leur vie et d'exister
même formellement et est aujourd'hui un
vrai enjeu d'amener les gens à
comprendre qu'on peut combiner des
revenus qu'on va dire de redistribution
mais aussi avoir une activité économique
existait pouvoir aller sur un marché où
est pas se cacher derrière le dos de
quelqu'un qui a sa carte avec ça et donc
voilà donc c'est ça l'enjeu
et là on est toujours chez moi donc un
petit atelier donc de transformation
agroalimentaire j c'est pour ça que
j'essaie de la recherche actions de fil
en aiguille on progresse comme ça et on
est contents de trouver des solutions et
d'améliorer les conditions de travail de
certains agents à l'heure actuelle non
c'est pas vraiment bien où se tourner et
encore plus pour moi quelqu'un qui
aujourd'hui à un problème de vue donc
franchement pour moi réussite et joël ça
a été beaucoup de portes ouvertes
là on est au siège de l'association
réussit bien quelques petits
désagréments parce que on est en plein
déménagement parce que dans quelques
jours on sera au tampon bonjour inhalent
alors ça va ça va
concrètement elle termine entrepreneurs
de tester son activité avance
immatriculé à sans vérifier la gamme et
économique de son projet ces derniers et
le bénévole qui est assez de recul
seulement pour pouvoir nous apporter sa
naissance stratégie sur l'effectif
couvert et c'est dans cette dynamique un
peu collaborative collective que on
trouvera à valoriser un peu mieux les
ressources qu'on a sur notre territoire